[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv78 nous sommes le
mercredi 25 octobre voici le programme
de ce soir le malheur des as fait le
bonheur des autres suite aux multiples
alertes à la bombe au château de
Versailles la fréquentation des autres
lieu culturel de la ville explose
découragé par les évacuations les
visiteurs se sont tournés vers l'espace
richot et le musée lambiné du savon
madeid in Eveline à carrière souspoissie
Magali Coch cocher Blin produit près de
4000 savons par an artisanal et
écologique le mois dernier elle a reçu
le prix de l'excellence de la chambre de
métier et de l'artisanat elle a accepté
de nous ouvrir les portes de son
laboratoire papounet duchesse ou encore
narco les 235 chiens et chats de la la
SPA de plaisir n'attendent que vous dans
ce nouveau numéro des animaux du 78 on
s'intéresse aux portes ouvertes de la
Société protectrice des animaux alors
que 16500 animaux ont été abandonnés cet
été en France cracheur de feu chevaux
féérique ou encore lampion le domaine de
Dierre en Eveline s'illumine ce samedi
28 octobre pour la nuit des châteaux on
en parle avec notre invité du 78 et ce
sera avec vous Pascal tevard bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes le directeur
général du domaine de Dierre en Evine
alors plusieurs animations sont prévues
pendant les vacances de la toussin mais
aussi ce weekend au domaine on en
parlera plus en détails en fin
d'émission avec nous également une
journaliste de la rédaction de tv78
Gabrielle bontier bonsoir bonsoir math
vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les evelines mais avant nous allons
prendre la direction de Versailles je
vous le disais à l'instant suite aux
multiples alertes à la bombe au château
la semaine dernière 7 en 8 jours les
milliers de visiteurs se sont rabatus B
sur d'autres lieux culturels de la Ville
ainsi l'espace richot et le musée
lambiné tous les deux situés à 20
minutes à pied du château ont observé
une hausse de fréquentation inédite le
nombre le nombre d'entrées a doublé je
vous propose d'écouter les propos de la
directrice de ces deux sites qui se
réjouit de cet effet d'auben ça a très
bien fonctionné ces deux ce weekend en
fait ces deux jours on a eu un chiffre
équivalent aux journéees européenne du
patrimoine ce qui est parmi les weekends
les plus remplis de notre côté on a eu
300 visiteurs au musée chaque jour et
puis 230 visiteurs ici à l'espace
richéchou alleiss c'est l'heure à
présent de passer aux informations du
jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines et on commence avec le chiffre
du jour Gabriel 150 pourquoi et bien 150
Mathilde c'est le nombre de personnes
qui vont être embauché en CDI par le
constructeur automobile Renault du site
historique de Flin un recrute qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la
reconversion progressive consacrée à
l'économie circulaire le
reconditionnement de véhicules
d'occasion et de pièces détaché de toute
marque c'est le projet refactory alors
un peu de patience he car ses embauches
se dérouleront entre 2024 et 2026 en
mars 2024 d'ailleurs sortira la toute
dernière voiture Zoé et c'est la
dernière ligne droite du concours
créatrice d'avenir le jury des Yveline a
rendu son verdict oui et CQ yvelinois
parviennent à la sélection régionale du
concours elle peuvent maintenant
prétendre accéder à la grande finale ces
créatrices d'entreprise représenteront
le département dans les six catégories
de prix impact innovation artisanat
mixité des ingénieurs quartier et prix
du public on le rappelle il s'agit du
premier concours francilien destiné à
l'entrepreneuriat des femmes les
lauréates pourront bénéficier d'une
visibilité et se partager 60000 €
prochaine étape donc le 7 novembre pour
désigner les 15 finalistes régionales on
va parler sport à présent et plus
particul particulièrement de basket
parce que ça y est c'est le grand soir
pour Victor wanama oui cette nuit le
natif du chînerocour fera son baptême du
feu en NBA face au Dallas Maveric en
début un début sans trop de stress
puisqu'il confiait lors d'une conférence
de presse cette nuit j'ai un peu des
papillons dans le ventre chez moi c'est
un peu le cas avant chaque match même si
ça dépend bien sûr des enjeux de
l'importance du match je ne me mets pas
à trembler à transpirer non plus mais
j'ai un peu mal au ventre on souhaite
donc bonne chance à inois coup d'envoi
cette nuit à 3h30 heure française et on
poursuit avec du football vous avez une
bonne nouvelle pour les supporters du FC
Versailles les supporters attendaient ça
avec impatience les Versaillais seront
de retour à montboron pour le prochain
match de Coupe de France ils
affronteront le FC Fleury 91 le samedi
28 octobre à 14h30 depuis la saison
dernière aucun match nationaux ne
pouvait se jouer sur le terrain sans
dérogation le stade versaillais est
toujours en travaux pour homologuer son
éclairage leur rencontre contre les
liyons se jouera à Versailles pour un
match de Coupe de France dans
l'après-midi donc aucun éclairage n'est
nécessaire et enfin direction Guill en
cour la ville nous propose de
redécouvrir les jeux vidéos de notre
jeunesse oui Sonic ou encore Pac-Man
tous vous accompagneront dans un univers
rétro et amusant pendant une après-midi
vous serez plongé dans un univers
vintage cet événement hors du temps vous
offrira également un moment familial qui
pourra bien être rempli de nostalgie on
l'imagine rendez-vous donc ce vendredi
27 octobre dès 14h30 au centre social du
pont du routtoir et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag setweet
news en France 75000 personnes en
situation de handicap sont entre
entrepreneur c'est notamment le cas de
Laurent Lapierre 58 ans ce trapiste a
lancé en septembre 2022 sa société
horizéo il termine actuellement la
conception d'un système motorisé pour
faciliter le déplacement des fauteuils
roulants dans les entreprises Julien
Leroi a rencontré ce patron plein
d'ambition
bonjour j'ai rendez-vous là-bas
normalement d'accord entrepreneur malgré
le handicap Laurent Lapierre 58 ans vit
attrape en juin 2017 suite à un accident
de motos cet ingénieur informatique
devient paraplégique constatant le
manque d'accessibilité pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite il décide
de concevoir un système pour améliorer
les déplacements au sein des entreprises
le principe adapté un dispositif
motorisé sur un fauteuil manuel sans
installation compliquée alors c'est
super simple on se met devant le
handinot on approche les roues avant on
met les roues avant dessus on appuie sur
un bouton et on part on peut aussi
l'équiper d'un panier pour pour faire
ses courses en voilà c'est c'est c'est
modulaire mais surtout c'est très simple
pour lancer son projet Laurent s'est
fait accompagner du ski cube à Montini
le Bretonneux cet incubateur de start-up
lui a permis de lancer horizeo en
septembre 2022 avec ses trois associés
une aventure entrepreneuriale malgré son
invalidité clairement j'aurais pas créé
cette société si j'avais pas été en
fauteuil parce que j'aurais même pas
imaginer le besoin en fait le handicap
est pas une barrière pour créer une
entreprise ça peut même mettre quelque
part une force parce que quand on a des
interlocuteurs qu'on dit qu'on est en
fauteuil ou et cetera ça crée une
relation qui est pas la même que si on
se parle de de de de valide à valide
centre commerciaux aéroport ougar voici
quelquesuns des potentiels futurs
clients de rizeo actuellement en Phe de
conception et de fabrication le handinot
commencera à être expérimenté dans les
sociétés au printemps 2024 tout comme
Laurent 75000 personnes en situation de
handicap en en France on fait le choix
de
l'entrepreneuriat on poursuit avec un
autre portrait en 2019 Magalie cocher
Blin décide de se reconvertir dans
l'artisanat et plus particulièrement
dans le savon cette habitante de
carrière souspissi crée sa propre
entreprise bain d'étoile elle a accepté
de nous ouvrir les portes de son
laboratoire c'est le reportage de
Gabriel
Gontier des formes des couleurs des
odeurs surtout beaucoup de savoir-faire
c'est ici depuis 2019 que Magalie cocher
Blin professeur de formation a créé sa
savonnerie après une reconversion
professionnelle au programme de la
matinée fabrication du savon Saint-Louis
on est avec de l'huile d'amande douce un
savon tout types de peau et on est plus
l'huile d'amonde douce c'est connu pour
adoucir assouplir la peau il y a de
l'argile verte dedans c'est de l'ilite
surfine donc je travaille qu'avec des
argiles françaises qui va enlever en
fait les les corps gras donc voilà c'est
celui-là qu'on va faire
pour la fabrication tout se passe en
laboratoire une conception au degrés et
au gram
[Musique]
près je vais vérifier la température
s'il y a besoin de monter je vais
monterter ça c'est l'huile d'olive on
est sur l'huile d'olive bio les recettes
sont déclarées au gram près on on est
déclaré à 0,01 g près ajouter à l'huile
la soude pour réaliser la saponification
vous avez vu il y a l'huile au-dessus et
en dessous ça commence à saponifier et
quand je
remue la saponification démarre
naturellement donc là ça veut dire que
l'huile est en train de se transformer
en savon à l'huile sont ajoutés des
éléments naturels ici de l'argile verte
là on est sur de l'élite argile
française sur fine c'est de l'argile
verte là je vais faire ce qu'on appelle
un one pot c'est un marbrage très très
classique la préparation est ensuite
versée dans des moules et devra
refroidir plusieurs heures pour ensuite
pouvoir être découpé à la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guitare il ne reste plus qu'à ajoutter
la touche finale la signature de
l'artisan une fois le séchage terminé
voici à quoi ressemble le savon avec
près de 4000 savons produits par an et
disponible des 7 € l'artisane fait
figure de référence en 2020 elle reçoit
par la ville de poissie le prix de femme
émérite une fierté au goût de revanche
pour l'ancienne professeur cétait pour
mon engagement écologique et puis la
création de bain d'étoile j'étais très
surprise puisque bain d'étoile avait 4
mois et 4 mois après recevoir ce type de
distinction voilà je me disais pourquoi
moi ça m'a donné un sacré là en fait ça
m'a permis de garder mes convictions et
puis d'aller plus loin
dans dans cette recherche de de
bien-être entre l'humain et et la nature
en septembre dernier c'est le prix de
l'excellence artisanale qui lui est
attribué faisant d'elle la seule artisan
d'excellence sabonnière siririère de
France à ce
jour c'est l'heure à présent de votre
numéro les animaux du 78 ce soir
direction la SPA de plaisir la Société
Protectrice pardon des animaux organisé
début octobre ses portes ouvertes
l'objectif incité à l'adoption
responsable alors que près de 16500
animaux ont été abandonnés l'été dernier
en France au refuge de plaisir willin de
nos confrères de radio sensation a suivi
les préparatifs de nos de ces journées
au combien importantes pour
[Musique]
l'association simus narco Papouné ou
encore duchesse ils sont 235 chiens et
chats au sein du refuge de plaisir à
vouloir trouver une famille d'adoption
chaque année la SPA de plaisir organise
deux weekends de journées portes
ouvertes etodit tu es chef d'équipe à la
société protectrice des animaux du de de
plaisir quels sont les objectifs des
journées portes ouvertes ça va être de
faciliter l'accès au au refuge les
rencontres des animaux on est vraiment
ouvert à tout public ces journées-là de
maximiser les adoptions d'avoir de
belles adoptions pour autant qu'elles
soi toujours responsable et c'est aussi
des moments d'échange puisquon a des
gens qui vont venir juste par exemple
pour avoir des conseils et aussi faire
de la sensibilisation pour la protection
animale mais avant d'ouvrir les portes
au public il faut notamment laver les
box préparer les chiens et les
sortir l divine avant l'ouverture des
des portes du coup donc vous êtes en
train de nettoyer les boxes des des
chiens pourquoi c'est important de
nettoyer les boxes des animaux ils ont
le droit tout comme nous d'avoir une
hygiène de vivre dans des conditions qui
sont salubres en fait c'est comme pour
nous ils méritent la même chose il
rentent ils reviennent de balade ou de
parc et ils sont dans des conditions
nickel pour une question de santé aussi
vérifier en même temps de ça permet de
contrôler aussi si certains sont malades
ou pas et pour se préparer à cette
journée les bénévoles promènent les
chiens je vais aller avec Mary et
cassgin en
balade combien de temps de balade est
organisé avec avec chaque chien et
qu'est-ce que ça leur permet pour cette
journée de porte ouvertes donc chaque
chien on une promenade à peu près de 30
35 minutes ça leur fait beaucoup de bien
parce que ça les sort bon B de déjà de
leur boxe c'est aussi un moment de
connivance avec la personne avec lequel
avec le CEL il son vous êtes avec casgin
dit granouche est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un peu plus de de ce chien
et Ben granouche est là déjà depuis
plusieurs mois un chien très attachant
bon qui a besoin de se dépenser quand
même pas mal il a fait déjà des
canicross où il s'est très bien défendu
c'est vraiment un chien qui n'est pas
méchant qui n'est pas du tout agressif
qui est dynamique mais très mignon une
balade qui dépense et canalise les
chiens du refuge mais il est déjà temps
pour cas grin de rentrer lui et 234
autres animaux de compagnie attendent
d'être adopté à la SPA de plaisir cet
été
16498 animaux ont été abandonnés sur les
routes de France en 2022 la France était
une nouvelle fois tristement championne
des
abandons lampe suspension ou lampe à
d'air jusqu'au 24 février 2024 le musée
de la ville de Saint-Quentin en niveline
vous plonge dans l'histoire des
luminaires des années 60 à 80 découverte
de cette collection lumineuse avec son
directeur Frédéric
debûche une exposition pour éclairer sa
lanterne le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline propose les
allumés du design ce voyage à travers le
temps des années 60 à 80 met en lumière
les luminaires lampes articulées spot ou
suspension décorative ces appareils
électriques occupent aujourd'hui une
place centrale dans notre quotidien et
durant les années pop un foisonnement
d'inventivité des créateurs avec une une
une grande remise en cause du luminaire
traditionnel l'invention de de formes
nouvelles et pour aller jusqu'à des
parfois des luminaires qui ressemblent à
tout sauf à des luminaires puisqu'on est
aussi dans dans une période un petit peu
antionformiste on aime bien détruire les
les styles ou les genres des générations
précédentes depuis 1879 et la conception
de l'ampoule à incandescence ces objets
ont connu de nombreuses évolutions avant
tout consacrés à la fonction d'éclairage
la lampe crée des ambiances lumineuse
dans les foyers dès les années 60 c'est
aussi un peu un âge d'or de la vie
familiale de la vie sociale on reçoit
beaucoup et donc
l'intérieur on y accorde une place très
très importante on on le soigne de forme
particulière grâce à l'arrivée du
plastique fait au sculpté avec l'ampoule
halogène les progrès technologiques ont
permis une plus grande audace artistique
comme avec ses luminaires conçus par des
créateurs italiens ces pil sont en fait
des des pilules géantes qui qui
deviennent des des lampes donc
c'est aussi des des une esthétique qui
qui s'inscrit dans ce qu'on appelle
l'antiign d'inspiration pop art ou
minimaliste environ 80 lampes présentent
l'émergence du des une contemporain au
musée de la ville de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline des idées lumineuses à retrouver
jusqu'au 24 février
2024 et cet automne il n'y a pas que les
feuilles des arbres qui changent de
couleur les jardins du château de Dierre
en Yveline retrouvent aussi leur
couleurs d'Halloween citrouille sorcière
ou encore fantôm reviennent pendant les
vacances de la toussin le reportage de
Patrick Jacques de dixmud et de Régine
[Musique]
ralche
la fête d'Halloween fait son retour au
château de Dierre pendant les vacances
de la toussin le domaine se prête au jeu
citrouille tourbillon de crisantthème
bougie un décor qui ne laisse pas ind
différent je me suis posé la question
c'est comment on peut avoir autant de
citrouille et c'est remarquablement
décoré et c'est bien c'est c'est génial
je trouve et c'est une excellente idée
ça va très bien avec le ver vert avec la
plousse qui est magnifique non non c'est
c'est très beau c'est non non c'est bien
faut continuer également au programme de
ces vacances des ateliers et des
animations pour les petits et les grands
on a pas mal de personnes qui vont venir
pour voir les décorations qu'on a mis
qui vont venir aussi pour les enfants
pour leur permettre aussi tout
simplement de d'avoir cette lecture de
compte on a aussi des balades à poneis
donc ça leur permet de faire une sortie
tranquillement et pas très loin de Paris
pour les vacances le domaine propose des
tarifs réduits à partir de 3,50 € la
date à pas manqué le samedi 28 octobre
le domaine restera ouvert jusqu'à 22h
pour la nuit des châteaux et on en parle
juste après mais avant je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'œil à la météo de
demain demain matin le temps sera mitigé
nous devrions avoir quelques averses sur
l'ensemble des ivelines côté température
compté 12 de°gr à rambouiller et 13°gr à
Oudan mont-el jolie et Versailles durant
l'après-midi le temps va se dégradé nous
devrions avoir de la pluie alors
prévoyez votre parapluie au niveau des
températures il fera 14 à rambouiller 15
à Houdan et Versailles et 16 à Mantel
jolie et demain nous fêterons la
saintdimitri c'est l'heure à présent de
passer à l'invité du
[Musique]
78 ce samedi 28 octobre c'est la nuit
des châteaux partout en France et pour
cette C 5e édition le domaine de
dempierre en Eveline fait de nouveau
partie de l'aventure pour en parler avec
nous Pascal téard le directeur général
du domaine alors dès 18h vous ouvrez vos
portes au public pourquoi c'est
important une nouvelle fois encore cette
année de participer à la nuit des
châteaux pour vous c'est important parce
que c'est la mise en lumière sur le
patrimoine et évidemment Dierre quel
beau patrimoine et c'est pour ça qu'on
adhère à ce à ce mouvement depuis depuis
l'origine on est on a ouvert nos portes
nous au moment où ça se créé et tout de
suite on a suivi ce cet élan des
propriétaires privés c'est une
association de propriétaires privés plus
de 100 voire 150 en France et on décide
de faire cette mise en lumière sur le
patrimoine et donc dans pierre
évidemment la mise en lumière se fait
puisque c'est un chantier qui avance
dans sa restauration et donc cette mise
en lumière à chaque fois permet de
mettre en valeur un élément nouveau
chaque année oui c'est l'occasion de
découvrir d'une autre manière ce
patrimoine yvelinois exactement c'est
c'est c'est il y a des format qui existe
en France chez des collègues où c'est
plutôt en comité restreint on se
découvre le patrimoine nous on ouvre les
portes vous disiez 18h on peut même
arriver dès 10h parce que tout ça c'est
le même tarif pour toute la journée sil
fait beau c'est passer la journée et
puis à partir de 18h et bien tout
doucement avec la nuit qui tombe le
château se met en lumière et là on peut
se promener avec des lampions et puis
avoir des animations pour pour profiter
de cette soirée alors au programme on a
cracheur de feu jongleur de feu et aussi
des chevaux fériques et voilà et donc on
a cette année des des des animations
autour de la lumière autour du feu la
première chose déjà c'est la première
fois qu'on montre au public l'éclairage
scénographié de du château maintenant
qu'il est restauré euh et puis pour
accompagner et bien on a fait appel à
une troupe qui va se déambuler avec des
cracheurs de feu comme vous disiez des
des des jongleurs de feu des chevaux
lumineux et puis tout ça avec un comment
les flleot baroc qui sont un un ensemble
baroc de sarim les chevreus qui vient
animer musique baroque et on peut même
danser près du kiosque et bien on peut
danser au son de la musique donc tout ça
c'est vraiment une soirée tout à fait
sympathique à Dierre dans les 90
hectares de jardin on pourra se perdre
et puis la lumière nous attirera pour
revenir vers le château et alors c'est
quoi un cheval lumineux un cheval
lumineux c'est un cheval qui évolue dans
le noir avec des rubans lumineux qui
progressent au milieu du public et et et
toute la concentration du cheval et de
son cavalier parce que les deux en fait
sont très concentrés et bien c'est de
montrer le geste et le les muscles des
des chevaux parce que on en aura
plusieurs à cette soirée dans le noir et
donc c'est c'est vraiment quelque chose
de très magique et puis tout ça au
milieu du public qui se promènera et qui
pourra admirer c'est vraiment une force
de la nature une force une force
artistique tout ça au pied du château
Gabriel l'idée c'est d'émerveiller on
l'a compris un peu plus les visiteurs
chaque année comment comment est-ce que
c'est pensé tout ça c'est des mois de
travail c'est c'est une collaboration
avec plusieurs acteurs euh oui oui c'est
des mois de travail ça c'est certain
c'est euh par exemple à la nuit des
châteaux de l'année dernière on avait
fait une petite introduction dans le
parcours avec ce un cheval pour voir
comment il se comportait enfin voilà
vous voyez déjà 12 mois avant on avait
déjà préparé le le comment ce ce cette
scénographie pour cette année 2023
l'année 2024 on commence aussi à travers
la la soirée de de samedi soir
évidemment à poser des pions pour voir
comment ça va bouger ou pas pour 2024 là
l'avantage c'est qu'on a un château qui
est déchafaudé où les chantiers des
jardins n'a pas commencé et donc du coup
on pourra profiter pleinement du site
euh pour passer cette nuit très agréable
et d'ailleurs ça va être le clou du
spectacle puisque la façade du château
sera illuminée alors la façade du
château l'année dernière avait été
illuminée par ce mapping mais il y avait
encore des éléments d'échafaudage il y
avait encore des palissades et là
vraiment on voit l'ensemble de la façade
avec des parcours éclairés par des ch
comme d'habitude autour de l'ét dans les
jardins et cetera mais là on va vraiment
voir et avec la lumière patrimoniale je
dire vous savez tous les monuments ont
une lumière particulière et donc là
c'est ce qui se passe sur l'escalier il
y a des bandeaux lumineux qui sont qui
ont été installés prévu par lesturs de
Pierre donc tout ça c'est intégré les
les façades les lanternes aussi sur les
Commins qui qui ont été refaits donc
tout ça voilà on montre au public la
restauration du patrimoine mais aussi
ben les nouveautés de ce patrimoine vous
savez déjà à peu près combien de
personnes vous attendez pour cet
événement tous les ans on a 2000
personnes c'est devenu un rendez-vous
familial exactement c'est c'est devenu
un rendez-vous familial euh on est je
pense enfin je suis sûr d'ailleurs on a
plus 1500 réservations cette année c'est
pas obligé d'être réservé mais voyez les
gens à plus 1500 et et cette année j'ai
voulu marquer l'effort
euh par rapport à
l'inflation Haus des prix et autres et
bien je fais le tarif habituel d'une
visite en journée dire que j'ai pas
voulu c'est
et un gestet que j'ai vouu faire
c'estutre ça qu'on acèsjà réservation
jours avant enfin 2 jours avant pardon
1500 personnes c'est déjà fort et mais
ça veut dire que voilà le geste que l'on
fait d'accueillir du public de de rendre
accessible de ce patrimoine et bien
voilà par par ce prix vraiment j'allais
pas dire préférentiel on a vraiment fait
un effort pour dire voilà on fait ce
prix dans le contexte actuel de hausse
de prix et et puis le contexte un peu
oxyogène et bien venez
découvrir ça ce sont des images de
l'année dernière enfin c'était aussi
magique l'née long terme alors tout à
l'heure vous avez parlé de la rénovation
du château il y a aussi beaucoup de
travaux qui ont été faits est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous nous expliquer
quels sont les travaux qui ont été faits
dernièrement et quels sont les travaux
qui sont à venir vous avez raison parce
que ça fait quand même depuis janvier
2020 que le chantier a commencé sur sur
damppierre euh on a terminé en mai 2022
l'écharpant de couverture et les façades
en avril 2023 on a terminé tout ce qui
était la restauration des dou la
restauration d'escalier ce qui permis
d'enlever toutes les palissades les
derniers échafaudage on a encore des
gros travaux sur place la création d'un
parking pour pouvoir accueillir à partir
de 2024 le public qu'on attend parce que
pour l'instant les conditions sont un
peu difficiles la l'extension d'une
boutique
billetterie pour pouvoir avoir les
structures d'accueil et puis surtout
pour le patrimoine on est en train de
restaurer les cours on achèvera la cour
principale et donc toutes les cours le
programme sera achevé pour l'ouverture
de mars prochain mars 2024 et en février
on va poser la grille d'honneur donc
voilà les grandes cours vont être
restaurées le public pourra le
fréquenter à partir de mars 2024
prochain notre ouverture parce qu'on
ferme le 5 novembre prochain la grille
d'honneur sera posée et pendant ce
temps-là et bien on espère pouvoir
commencer cet hiver ça a un petit peu
décalé pour des raisons techniques mais
les décisions vont se prendre très
rapidement mais normalement on va
commencer la restauration des jardins
dit à la français c'està-dire les grands
bassins les grand jet d'eau tout ce qui
contrib la notoriété de dpierre au 17e
et 18e siècle et bien voilà ça va
revenir il y a malheureusement pour un
an de chantier donc il va falloir déjà
creuser un peu des idée pour l'année
prochaine pour accue le public mais
c'est aussi voilà la restauration du
patrimoine qui qui qui mérite ça donc
alors encore beaucoup de de travail pour
cet hiver on va revenir aux vacances de
la toussin jusqu'au 5 novembre il y a
beaucoup de d'animations et d'activités
qui sont proposé on l'a un petit peu vu
dans dans le reportage juste avant il y
a des comptes de l'attelage et même un
parcours deschimer ah oui alors ça les
parcours deschimer ça ça plaît
énormément aux familles c'est un
parcours qui qui est en fait accessible
à tous tout toute l'année mais là on met
on a mis un peu plus l'accent parcours
des chimè en fait on on l'a créé l'année
dernière dans les anciens jardins dans
les anciens bosquet qui ont été détruit
en 2000 en 2000 en 99 pardon par la
tempète de 1999 et donc du coup on a
recréé un parcours qui permet d'être à
la fois ludique et éducatif c'estàd
qu'on aborde l'histoire de France on
aborde l'histoire du domaine l'aborde
l'histoire des jardins et de
l'architecture tout en s'amusant parce
que il y a il y a des énigmes et puis
évidemment pour les enfants il y a un
petit cadeau donc c'est c'est un
parcours qui est libre complètement il y
a pas de droit d'accès spécifique c'est
le prix d'entrée vous demandez le petit
fascule et vous partez sur 1 km demi de
balade à travers on va pas spoiler le
petit le petit
cadeauà les enfants sont non non ça je
le dirai pas euh je ne dirai pas ce que
c'est et et d'ailleurs pour les comptes
puisque dans les animations de pour les
comptes on termine par offrir un goûter
d'accord les enfs ah ou mais les enfants
adorent Gabriel toutes ces animations
que vous mettez en place ça fait partie
intégrante de la vie d'un château
aujourd'hui ça fait partie d'un site
touristique parce que c'est un château
c'est un site patrimonial mais il faut
faire vivre il faut il faut dynamiser le
patrimoine doit être connu le patrimoine
comme dans pierre est aux portes de
Saint-Quentin vraiment on a quelques
minutes et malheureusement il est fort
ignoré et donc du coup de faire ses
animations permet de faire découvrir une
histoire histoire du Duchet de Chevreuse
parce que le le domaine de Dierre c'est
avant tout le fief du Duchet de
Chevreuse et Saint-Quentin il est au
cœur du Duchet Chevreuse historiquement
donc c'est l'histoire locale et et et
Adam piierre ça rejoint l'histoire
nationale et donc de venir ça permet ça
permet de de de participer à l'éducation
de de tous à la culture de tous sur sur
le comment sur notre histoire commune et
bien merci beaucoup Pascal tvard d'avoir
répondu à question
mer alors pour Rapp la nuit des château
domain deierel c'est ce samedi 28
octobre à 18h le billet est à 8 € et
pour les activités durant les vacances
de la tous c'est jusqu'au 5 novembre de
10h à 18h et c'est la fin de ce 78 merci
pour votre fidélité tout de suite
retrouvez votre chronique éducation avec
Régine ralèche je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]